et pour ce club des territoires on va
parler de ce texte voté au Sénat qui
vise à encadrer les pratiques des
influenceurs et à lutter contre les
dérives sur les réseaux sociaux on va
tout vous expliquer ne vous inquiétez
pas ce qu'est un influenceur ce que va
changer ce texte ce que vous pouvez
faire si vous êtes victime de ces
pratiques et pour en parler nous sommes
avec Amel caca bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous c'est notre finition
centrices du Pas-de-Calais vous êtes la
rapporteur de ce texte qui a été voté au
Sénat Karine Fernandez bonjour
présidente de l'unique l'Union des
métiers de l'influence et des créateurs
de contenu c'est tout récent ça a été
créé en janvier 2023 vous nous direz
justement en quoi ça consiste et
Clotilde de Biron bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes avocate enseignante
en droit numérique d'abord pour nos
téléspectateurs qui ne savent peut-être
pas tout simplement ce qu'est un
influenceur quelle définition on peut
donner à ce mot avec le caca alors je
vais reprendre la définition telle
qu'elle a été définie notamment et votée
dans le cadre de l'assemblée sénatori le
mardi mardi soir puisque vous l'avez
très justement dit l'idée où l'objet de
cette proposition de loi à la base
c'était bien de définir en tout cas un
cadre juridique autour de cette activité
d'influenceurs commerciales et la
définition c'est donc c'est une personne
physique et morale qui est aujourd'hui à
titre onéreux c'est à dire en
contrepartie d'une rémunération en
contrepartie et d'un bénéfice commercial
en contrepartie du en contrepartie voilà
de d'un avantage en nature va promouvoir
un bien un service ou une cause quelle
qu'elle soit par voie électronique donc
voilà comment elle a été définie
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cette
proposition de loi Karine est-ce qu'il y
a une différence entre un influenceur et
un créateur de contenu ou est-ce que
c'est la même chose on préfère le terme
créateur de contenu parce qu'on pense
que le terme influenceur va suggérer que
l'influence et une fin en soi et
finalement un créateur de contenu c'est
quelqu'un qui partage sa passion ses
valeurs etc sur les réseaux sociaux va
du coup agréger une communauté autour de
lui et du coup va faire qu'il a une
audience qui va le rendre connue infinie
et donc faire qu'il a une influence sur
cette audience donc on va préférer une
audience c'est combien à partir de
combien on dit qu'on est en influenceur
connu mais finalement alors connu c'est
toujours voilà c'est tout et ça a été un
débat d'ailleurs par rapport par rapport
à la définition on savait pas exactement
s'il fallait mettre une jauge etc connu
c'est c'est très compliqué à définir par
contre on devient influenceur de son
audience dès lors qu'on a des gens qui
nous suivent en fait on peut même être
un influenceur avec 500 abonnés du
moment que les gens nous suivent et qui
portent un intérêt à ce qu'on raconte
même nous dans notre quotidien et en
dehors des réseaux on influence notre
entourage par notre opinion donc ce qui
compte c'est ce qu'on appelle la
visibilité l'échange avec sa communauté
la crédibilité surtout en fait le ce qui
fait qu'on nous suit parce qu'on est
crédible ça nous rend du coup influence
influençant finalement sur des gens qui
peuvent être influencés mais c'est pas
négatif dans ce terme-là c'est qu'il
croit la personne et peuvent suivre son
opinion Clotilde Biron est-ce qu'il y a
un statut légal de l'influenceur une
définition légale aujourd'hui non donc
justement c'est ce que vient combler la
proposition de loi je rajouterais juste
euh par rapport à la définition en cette
proposition de loi est focalisée sur
l'activité d'influence commerciale parce
que l'influence au sens large alors je
m'appuie sur aucun texte juridique mais
c'est un leader d'opinion un influenceur
est un leader d'opinion donc il va
inciter à avoir des pratiques dans les
habitudes de vie ou des habitudes de
consommation mais pas que il peut aussi
guider des personnes ou en tout cas
voilà porter une opinion et fédérer ou
en tout cas faire adhérer à ses idées un
groupe de personnes concombres il y a
d'influenceurs aujourd'hui Carine
Fernandez en France on en recense 150
000 grâce aux différentes plateformes
technologiques et annuaires on en
ressent on en recense 150 000 donc c'est
c'est énorme tous aussi grand que petit
ouais on va venir sur le texte
amalgaquerre
d'abord peut-être un mot vous qui avez
évidemment beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question est-ce qu'il y a un profil de
l'influenceur qu'on peut définir alors
ça c'est été toute la difficulté ou
particularité justement du domaine de
cette activité d'influenceurs
commerciales et qui n'existe pas de
profil type pour mener ces travaux
d'ailleurs un des premiers objectifs
c'était ça c'est de faire connaissance
avec ce secteur de l'influence et on a
tous types d'influenceurs aujourd'hui ça
peut être la mamie qui parce que on
parle souvent des jeunes mais pas que
alors ce sont aussi le jeune à Dubaï
exactement
chez elle exactement voilà pourquoi j'ai
commencé par cet exemple donc on a et
c'est vraiment la pas la difficulté la
difficulté mais la particularité de ce
canal commercial numérique c'est de ne
pas avoir de profil type tout en sachant
quand même que la moyenne d'âge
généralement d'un influenceur en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on dit souvent d'une
trentaine d'années plutôt des femmes
mais encore une fois je le redis il n'y
a pas de profil type ça peut être
l'étudiant qui lui va le faire de temps
en temps et puis on a par contre un
chiffre intéressant à voir en tête
aujourd'hui sur les 150 000 influenceurs
seuls 15% en tout cas ce sont les
chiffres que nous avons aujourd'hui le
font à temps plein donc une petite
donc c'est une minorité quand même et ça
c'est intéressant de le suivre pour
d'autres c'est un complément de revenu
exactement de leur métier tout à fait
exactement justement sur la rémunération
d'un influenceur pour qu'on comprenne
bien comment ça marche est-ce que c'est
encadré
par contrat en fait les les influenceurs
qui contractent avec des annonceurs donc
des marques qui souhaitent faire de la
publicité en ligne via ce canal de
diffusion et bien va conclure vont
conclure un contrat et dans lequel va
être décrit les prestations que qui vont
être fournies par l'influenceur et la
contrepartie financière ou non parce que
parfois c'est des échanges c'est des
échanges des des cadeaux ou en tout cas
bon une contrepartie non financière
donnée à l'influenceur est-ce qu'on a
une idée car il faitent du revenu moyen
d'un influenceur aujourd'hui dans le
pays le revenu moyen c'est il est
compliqué à définir puisqu'il dépendent
beaucoup de facteurs et justement plus
on monte en notoriété plus on va se
retrouver sur des rémunérations d'image
comme ça peut être le cas pour pour un
acteur ou une personnalité publique mais
il faut surtout retenir que dire combien
de rémunération d'images on peut gagner
combien avec un chantier ça peut être ça
peut être quelques milliers d'euros par
mois quelques dizaines de milliers voire
plus ça dépend vraiment l'audience mais
par contre 80% de ces 150 000 créateurs
de contenu aujourd'hui gagnent moins de
5000 euros par an donc c'est vraiment
dire que on est sur des choses plutôt
ponctuelles qui permettent pas d'en
vivre du coup et qui font que c'est
plutôt quelque chose de secondaire dans
la vie des créateurs de contenu plutôt
que quelque chose de dominant vous avez
réussi à avoir des chiffres un peu
précis sur le revenu de ces influenceurs
combien ça rapporte alors justement et
nous avions nous avons les mêmes
chiffres que ceux qui viennent d'être
communiqués et c'est encore une fois je
le redis la difficulté du du secteur qui
est en fait un secteur assez jeune
puisque il a démarré il y a une petite
dizaine d'années et aujourd'hui en effet
c'est encadrement va nous permettre
justement d'y voir plus clair sur la
façon dont s'exerce ce secteur
d'activité et justement on va voir ce
que contient ce texte Audrey vous avez
suivi avec attention cette séance et
vous allez nous dire ce que contient le
texte pour encadrer l'influence sur les
réseaux sociaux le statut des
personnalités qu'il exerce et des
agences qui leur donnent c'est la
première fois qu'un Parlement se penche
sur la régulation de ce secteur en
Europe l'objectif c'est que l'influence
en pleine expansion ne soit plus une
zone de non-droit une zone floue alors
pour vous faire rapidement la navette
parlementaire le texte vient de
l'assemblée il a été adopté à
l'unanimité unanimité aussi mardi soir
au Sénat avec des ajustements alors
qu'elles sont-ils alors avec cette
nouvelle mouture du Sénat les
influenceurs devront afficher la mention
unique publicité sur leur publication
commerciale ils n'auront pas le droit à
votre initiative madame la rapporteur de
faire la promotion de l'abstention
thérapeutique des sachets de nicotine
dont la vente ben moi je l'ai appris se
développe chez les adolescents en ligne
ça vient s'ajouter à une autre
interdiction qui était prévue elle par
les députés la promotion de la chirurgie
esthétique autre ajout contre la vie du
gouvernement cette fois l'interdiction
de toute promotion portant atteinte à la
protection de la santé publique c'était
porté par la sénatrice salaire
Jacqueline ne s'arrinho et
l'interdiction de se mettre en scène
avec des animaux que l'on n'a pas le
droit de domestiquer en France c'était
porté par Arnaud Bazin les sanctions
aussi ont été alourdies après passage au
Sénat en cas de non-respects de ses
règles les influenceurs s'exposent à
deux ans d'emprisonnement au lieu de six
mois dans le texte des députés et
300.000 euros d'amandes toujours sous
votre contrôle alors certains à gauche
ce sont désolés que ces interdictions
n'aillent pas plus loin ils voulaient
notamment empêcher la promotion par des
mineurs de ce qui est trop gras trop
sucré trop salé et des jeux d'argent et
de hasard mais nous sommes sur une ligne
de crête car tout cela est autorisé dans
la publicité traditionnelle si on
l'interdit pour les influenceurs alors
on a une rupture d'égalité et ça c'est
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
en fait mardi soir on a senti dans les
débats les sénateurs de tout bord
avaient envie de mieux régulé la
publicité de manière générale alors
Sophie prima la présidente de la
commission des finances a signé non sans
humour la fin de ce match là en tout cas
moi j'engage à ce que des travaux soient
faits sur la publicité influenceurs pas
influenceur sur l'ensemble de la
publicité si vous voulez réguler la
publicité et bien faites des
propositions de loi là dessus mais ce
n'est pas le lieu quand je vous entends
parler des influenceurs qui sont un vrai
un vrai phénomène de société j'ai
l'impression d'entendre mes parents
parler de l'arrivée de la télévision
dans les années 70 donc je voudrais pas
que dans 20 ans on se réveille avec un
train de retard
commission des Affaires d'économiques
vous l'aurez compris alors en ce qui
concerne les influenceurs sénateurs et
députés devront maintenant se réunir en
commission mixte paritaire pour
s'entendre sur un texte qui convient aux
deux chambres
par rapport au texte qui vous est arrivé
de l'Assemblée à belgaca et en même
temps on l'a compris c'était compliqué
d'aller beaucoup plus loin oui alors
c'est le texte arrivé de l'Assemblée
nationale était déjà un texte et qui
faisait l'unanimité qui était déjà très
équilibrée
ce qu'on a souhaité c'était le
rééquilibrer le simplifier aussi parfois
ne serait-ce que sur la notion de
définition d'y ajouter aussi certaines
interdictions mais tout en gardant en
tête qu'on ne partait pas contrairement
à ce qu'il se disait on ne partait pas
d'un vide juridique à aujourd'hui il
existe un cadre légal Grégoire
et que j'ai dû rappeler à plusieurs
reprises c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il
existe un code de la publicité de la
promotion qui définit des règles des
interdictions et donc il s'agissait
surtout pas de faire ce qu'on nous
reproche parfois ce qu'on reproche au
législateur de mettre du droit dans le
droit la loi dans la loi et donc les
discussions parfois ou les ajustements
ont porté là-dessus donc il ne
s'agissait pas de s'opposer à des débats
de fond sur la malbouffe sur l'alcool
mais de dire il existe aujourd'hui un
cadre qui n'est pas assez connu par les
influenceurs qui n'est pas assez connue
par les agents d'influenceurs donc il
était bon de le rappeler c'était tout
l'intérêt aussi de cette PPL et de ne
pas forcément aller beaucoup plus loin
sauf et vous l'avez parfaitement frapper
je n'ai pas grand chose à ajouter sur
des interdictions 20 sur 20 22 sur 20 si
vous voulez mais sauf sur des
interdictions que nous avions relevé
dans le cadre des nombreuses heures
d'audition et qui nous paraissaient
importantes quand même de fixer sur
voilà c'était des lignes de craie qui
fait sur lesquelles il fallait se tenir
parce que dangereuse en terme de santé
publique notamment c'est un bon texte
qui sort du Sénat car une Fernandez pour
vous nous on est on est très contents
dans la dans la globalité du texte parce
que l'équilibre a été préservé donc ça
c'était essentiel pour nous et comme
vous l'avez rappelé c'était essentiel
aussi de pas mettre l'influence dans un
le secteur en tout cas de l'influence
dans un panier différent de celui du
secteur de la publicité digitale parce
qu'il y a déjà tout un ensemble de
règles maintenant c'est vrai qu'on va
aussi être assez attentif à ce qui va se
passer avec la CMP notamment parce que
il y a encore un peu de flou notamment
sur la question de la santé il y a des
interdictions qui ont été renforcées à
l'issue du vote au Sénat et donc on se
pose un petit peu la question de savoir
jusqu'où ça va et qu'est-ce que ça veut
interdire sur les par exemple justement
c'était évoqué tout à l'heure le fait de
vouloir interdire toute forme de
promotion directe ou indirecte autour
des sujets de santé et liés à la santé
publique portant atteinte à la
protection de donc beaucoup l'ont
compris comme une interdiction au
globale c'est ce qu'on a vu en tout cas
dans les médias mais une interdiction au
globale de parler de la santé tout court
on pense que c'est un peu flou parce que
justement la santé publique du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on va
chercher qu'est-ce qu'on va pas chercher
et aujourd'hui il y a des agences des
créateurs de contenu qui sont
kinésithérapeutes médecins ou autre et
qui travaillent avec l'Ordre des
médecins au quotidien pour mettre en
place leur campagne autour de la santé
et la sensibilisation qui du coup
pourrait si c'était une interdiction
globale le plus du tout pouvoir
travailler alors qu'ils ont un vrai rôle
dans le secteur je vais laisser répondre
à belgaca avant de vous entendre petit
Biron là dessus sur les inquiétudes
quand même oui inquiétude que nous
entendons que nous avions déjà entendu
et je le redis hormis les quelques
dispositions qui ont été rappelées
chirurgie esthétique abstention
thérapeutique sachet de nicotine
voilà l'idée c'est de ne pas aller plus
loin que le cadre légal donc nous
resterons de toute façon sur en tout cas
voilà ce sont des échanges qui ont lieu
dans le cadre de cette commission mixte
paritaire mais l'idée c'est de ne pas
interdire plus que ce qui existe
aujourd'hui en plus de ce qu'on a évoqué
qui nous paraissait encore une fois être
menaçant pour la santé publique
notamment de nos jeunes avec le titre
Biron sur ce texte d'abord quel est
votre avis sur ce texte et puis après je
poserai la question sur le fameux vie
juridique le texte à l'avantage de
d'année la clarté c'était une clarté qui
était nécessaire parce que on a vu les
dérives les dérives dans le secteur je
suis en tout point d'accord avec Amel
gacer sur le fait que ce n'était pas un
vide qu'il n'y avait pas de vie
juridique à combler en réalité c'était
plus un flou on a même parlé du Far West
dans dans le secteur concrètement c'est
à dire concrètement la loi est là on est
dans le secteur dans un secteur de
publicité et la loi dit clairement que
la publicité qui ne dit pas son et donc
est interdite c'est une pratique
commerciale trompeuse qui est déjà
sanctionné par par les textes français
mais les influenceurs ne se sentaient
pas concernés absolument il y avait deux
chats voilà une méconnaissance pure et
simple de la loi qui existait donc voilà
donc ce texte au moins l'avantage de
venir sensibiliser davantage et de
d'apporter une pédagogie aux acteurs de
l'influence les influenceurs en premier
et puis à l'avantage aussi d'une
certaine façon de venir condenser un
petit peu toutes les règles qui
existaient de manière disparate jusqu'à
présent dans les textes on a en matière
de publicité on peut retrouver des
règles dans le code de la santé publique
justement avec les l'obligations de
faire mentionner des des formules
sensibilisation sanitaires Manger Bouger
etc etc donc là ça l'avantage de venir
concentrer tout ça dans un texte unique
et ce qui est pas mal pour pouvoir faire
appliquer toutes ces règles
Olivia Grégoire elle a dit aussi que ce
texte répondait à une demande populaire
c'est le c'est le sentiment que vous
avez eu à Malga car oui qui est lié j'ai
envie de dire à la médiatisation sur
médiatisation de ces influenceurs
aujourd'hui auteur des dérivés et
d'arnaque ces grandes stars de la
téléréalité parce qu'on parle souvent
d'eux et j'ai envie de dire et c'était
ma ligne de conduite dans la façon des
j'ai venu mener ces travaux c'était de
ne surtout pas jeter l'opprobre en fait
clairement sur ce secteur qui a un
secteur d'activité comme un autre bien
sûr avec des spécificités avec des
dérives évidemment mais l'idée c'était
de se dire encore une fois que il
fallait aujourd'hui
l'encadrer véritablement et puis
renforcer par contre les moyens de
sanction pour ceux qui cette fois-ci ne
respecterait pas ce cadre légal et ça va
donner peut-être ce texte aussi une
meilleure image des influenceurs qui
étaient peut-être
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé parler
des dérives et de ces stars
effectivement souvent des téléréalités
qui faisaient des dérives et qui
faisaient de l'ombre à la grande
majorité des influenceurs qui font leur
métier et leur activité de manière tout
à fait claire ça va ça va ça va
faciliter les choses en tout cas au
moins il y aura plus de flou sur cette
sur cette question et c'est vrai que
même nous et même avec les plus grands
experts de la publicité parfois on se
posait la question est-ce qu'on a bien
fait pas bien fait est-ce que c'est
comme il faut comment faire à quoi on se
réfère et à la RPP déjà qui qui mène un
travail depuis très longtemps et qui
nous guide sur les bonnes pratiques mais
au moins là ce sera ce sera officiel par
contre soyons vigilants je pense aussi
sur l'adaptabilité à réseaux sociaux
parce que dans deux ans on sait pas quel
sera le nouveau social qui va émerger
quand on voit du coup que dans la loi il
va être demandé par exemple de maintenir
sur une sur une communication un contenu
en entier un bandeau ou une
signalisation qui va dire que ce contenu
est sponsorisé par une marque quand bien
même sur 10 minutes de contenu il y a 30
secondes de sponsorisation bon déjà
c'est ça ne s'applique pas sur les
autres secteurs aujourd'hui de publicité
et surtout quid des réseaux vocaux par
exemple qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur un
podcast est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une voix en continu du coup qui disent
c'est sponso c'est sponso c'est sponso
enfin voilà il y a un ensemble de choses
je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à figer
dans le dans le texte ce qui est
essentiel et qu'on arrive à garder une
part de flexibilité pour ce qui va se
passer demain et c'est dérives dont on a
parlé c'est dérives des influenceurs
elles ont fait des victimes Cécile Sixou
est allé rencontrer l'une d'entre elles
on écoute son témoignage tu es dingue
enfin franchement j'en rajoute pas je
vous promets que vous avez mais la peau
hyper doucement une marque de qualité
c'est une marque suédoise et franchement
on est trop bien dedans ça sent vraiment
très peu ils sont suivis par des
milliers de personnes et font la
promotion de produits sans signalés
qu'ils ont signé un partenariat ou qu'un
achat engage à un abonnement un autre
certains influenceurs abusent leur
notoriété pour gagner de l'argent des
tromperies aux escroqueries certains en
ont fait les frais c'est le cas de Slim
il a suivi les conseils d'un instagramur
très en vue pour faire des
investissements financiers toutes les
lignes que vous voyez là ce sont des
transactions qui m'ont été envoyées par
le par l'influenceur en question donc
des transactions financières à prendre
sur sur le site du courtier donc là on
peut voir par exemple sur cette
transaction là qui a été prise le 16
août 2021 que j'ai perdu 121 euros au
bout d'un an il a perdu 1500 euros il a
également acheté des NFC de l'art
virtuel pour 2400 euros en échange de
promesses de gains facile par exemple il
disait que
les 15 premières cartes sont des cartes
légendaires elle rapporteront
automatiquement 2500 dollars tous les
mois à vie je me suis aperçu que c'était
une arnaque au bout d'un an été frustré
parce que je me suis dit que cette
influenceur là a beaucoup d'abonnés et
qu'il arrive à convaincre beaucoup de
gens à tomber dans le panneau et que en
termes de vu que nous n'avons pas
d'audience nous pouvons rien faire c'est
même nous exprimer à travers nos réseaux
sociaux la portée est très petite nous
avons quoi à une centaine d'abonnés
chacun alors que lui il y a des millions
d'abonnés donc face à lui face à ces
influenceurs là on notre voit n'est pas
portée donc il continue leur manigances
et leurs arnaques sans que nous soyons
entendus
en 2022 spams s'aperçoit qu'il n'est pas
seul et décide de créer une association
de victimes aujourd'hui son collectif
reçoit des centaines de messages
quotidiens et regroupent les plantes les
gens partaient plainte un peu partout
donc vous en avez un qui porte plainte à
Bordeaux un à Paris 1 à Marseille à Nice
etc et les procureurs il reçoit à chaque
fois une plainte ils disent bon allez
c'est sans suite donc le fait de
regrouper tous les plaignants et qu'on
dépose une place chez un seul procureur
avec des centaines de plaignants je
pense que ça fait une grosse différence
une différence car jusqu'à présent
l'activité des influenceurs n'est pas
encore encadré ils sont 150000 en France
et selon cette spécialiste du marketing
d'influence ce sont surtout les profils
exportés à Dubaï qui posent problème il
faut être super vigilant il y a des gens
très bien très honnêtes mais la partie
la moins honnête c'est aussi celle qui
peut faire le plus de mal parce que
l'audience et l'impact est très gros ils
ont des de très grosses audiences très
jeunes qui sont très influença très
malléable et si demain il leur disent
cette personne allait la démonter sur
les réseaux sociaux ils vont y aller
pour elle un meilleur contrôle des
influenceurs passe avant tout par leur
formation on a l'exemple Anne pas suivre
parce qu'en gros il y a pas la mention
partenariat rémunérée et qui est de la
plateforme ou normalement qui est
affiché en haut on réduira l'impact je
dirais des arnaques auprès du
consommateur final si le le la personne
qui à travers laquelle transit
l'information à savoir le profil et
suffisamment au courant et bien encadré
donc je mettrai plutôt un taux d'effort
sur l'information l'éducation et le
cadrage de ces profils là plutôt que sur
le consommateur final la future loi
devrait donner tous les outils
législatifs pour mieux sanctionner ce
qui abuserait
elles ont du mal à se faire entendre
face aux géants de l'influence avec des
milliers des millions d'abonnés
oui et c'est tout l'intérêt de cette PPL
qui est d'ores et déjà de mettre en
place ce cadre juridique qui va
permettre d'avoir une accroche une
attache pour pouvoir aller plus loin
véritablement vous voyez là vous vous
demandiez tout à l'heure vous parliez de
l'annonce enfin de la demande populaire
et bien c'est vraiment celle-ci qui
reflète en effet les situations
dramatiques parfois dans lesquelles
peuvent être certaines victimes donc
collective que j'ai eu l'occasion en
effet d'auditionner à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre de la préparation de
l'examen de cette PPL quand les recours
pour ces victimes est-ce qu'elles ont
des recours possible est-ce qu'elles
peuvent se faire entendre aujourd'hui
oui il y a des dispositifs légaux pour
pour se faire entendre le dépôt de
plainte et là on voit dans le comme le
comme on peut le constater dans le
témoignage malheureusement non parce que
vous imaginez le nombre que peuvent
représenter ces victimes
il y a une solution le de recours à les
recours collectifs qui ont été
introduits par la loi Hamon
néanmoins en pratique ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que ces recours sont rares
et sont fastidieux à mettre en place
donc effectivement on a pu ressentir une
frustration de la part de la part des
justiciables et donc c'est pour ça que
en mettant enfin en tout cas c'est le
l'objectif de la proposition de loi
c'était d'avoir un effet dissuasif
limité autant que possible que ce cas de
figure se reproduise parce que là
malheureusement pour tout ce qu'on a
déjà constaté pour toutes les dérives la
proposition de loi ne va malheureusement
pas pouvoir régler ses soucis là
puisqu'ils sont arrivés avant l'entrée
en vigueur de l'application de la loi
elle arrive un peu tard cette
proposition de loi
tard peut-être qu'il fallait ce temps
peut-être pour constater effectivement
on peut regretter le timing mais c'est
souvent comme ça la loi aussi vient en
fonction des circonstances alors juste
on parle de cette loi qui arrive un peu
tard nous sommes quand même en France le
premier pays au sein d'une européenne à
légiférer sur dans ce domaine-là donc je
pense que c'est intéressant et important
de le mentionner je le redis c'est un
secteur jaune et autre point aussi qui
se réglera pas par la proposition de loi
mais c'est la sensibilisation du public
aussi il y a une vraie effort de de
pédagogie à l'égard aussi de la cible
que touche ses influenceurs il faut
aussi éveiller voilà les les personnes
au caractère illicite de tel ou tel
publicité ou telle ou tel produit etc si
clairement la personne présente un
produit de contrefaçon on sait très bien
qu'en France c'est interdit on n'achète
pas un produit de contrefaçon
sur la partie sensibilisation c'est vrai
que les collectifs et notamment celui
dont vous avez parlé là d'ailleurs je
les salue il faut un travail incroyable
ça demande beaucoup d'énergie de
recenser tout ça et de permettre aux
gens de se regrouper je pense que ça a
eu un véritable effet de sensibilisation
déjà auprès du grand public parce que ça
a été relayé partout dans les médias
mais par contre responsabilisons aussi
les plateformes je pense que c'est
essentiel parce que du coup cette loi va
permettre je pense d'aller plus vite
d'identifier plus vite les problèmes et
du coup on se rend vraiment compte que
c'est en potentiellement en éteignant
certains comptes de créateurs de contenu
que justement là on arrête le problème
et qu'on est capable de se dire ok tu ne
peux plus parler donc du coup tu ne peux
plus faire de mal et du coup de c'est
essentiel les plateformes doivent avoir
leur responsabilité à mon sens Audrey
après je vous donne et en séance la
ministre Olivier agrégoire a annoncé une
augmentation du nombre d'agents de la
répression des fraudes alors il faudra
attendre le projet de loi finance pour
savoir combien d'agents en plus mais
elle a prévu des agences supplémentaires
justement pour repérer ses fraudes et il
y a une autre mesure qui a été annoncée
par le gouvernement c'est Bruno Le Maire
qui a annoncé qu'il allait rendre
prochainement public les sanctions
prises à l'encontre de certains
influenceurs 60% des influenceurs
contrôlés d'immis font l'objet de
constat d'infraction c'est la bonne
méthode de rendre public les noms des
gens
tout ce qui est aujourd'hui va concourir
à mieux protéger les consommateurs pour
ma part et quelque chose de positif donc
cette technique du néman shame on
apprécie on apprécie pas pour tout vous
dire nous cette question a été posée au
sein de l'assemblée sénatoriale nous
n'avons pas souhaité aller plus loin
parce que c'est ça fait l'objet en fait
d'un amendement je trouve cela encore
une fois pourquoi pas intéressant parce
que j'ai en tête encore une fois notre
objectif premier qui est de protéger les
consommateurs sur Internet
cette manière de rendre public les
sanctions ça vous paraît la bonne
méthode Karine Fernandel comme on pour
l'instant en plus on ne sait pas quels
sont les noms qui sont prévus à être
annoncés donc difficiles pour moi de
commenter par contre c'est vrai que il
faudra voir dans quelle manière c'est
c'est de les rendre public sur la
méthode pourquoi
si on est sur de la mise en danger de
consommateur était pratique
véritablement dangereux je pense que
c'est essentiel parce que du coup
justement encore une fois on revient sur
la sensibilisation du du consommateur à
tout ça par contre voilà voyons comment
c'est fait effectivement et je sais que
encore au quotidien aujourd'hui et comme
on l'expliquait il y a une vraie
sensibilisation aussi à faire auprès des
créateurs de contenu qui très souvent
par exemple vont oublier ou mal mettre
l'identification de la publicité plutôt
par non savoir plutôt que par volonté de
nuire et donc c'est important de pas
mettre sur le même niveau finalement
quelqu'un qui arnaque sciemment et veut
faire du mal plutôt que quelqu'un qui a
fait un oubli de bonne foi
je suis assez partagée sur sur le sujet
déjà le Diamond shame est déjà fait
aussi par d'autres autorités
administratives je pense notamment à la
CNIL pour tout ce qui est sanctions en
cas de non conformité aux règles sur la
protection des données à caractère
personnel donc pourquoi pas
effectivement rendre public des
sanctions des sanctions les plus
importantes je vois l'autre contrepartie
c'est attention à ne pas ensuite tomber
dans des dérives qui seraient que chaque
victime ou en tout cas le les
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux se
fassent just eux-mêmes et on retombe on
tombe dans un autre effet que serait le
du cyber-harcèlement parce que bon les
influenceurs restent quand même des
personnes physiques pour la plupart même
si parfois c'est ils ont des sociétés
qui qui exploitent leur compte mais
c'est des personnes physiques donc
attention à ne pas tomber après sur du
cyber-harcèlement etc et on connaît donc
son victime on vous le dites certains
influenceurs et là il y a un autre texte
qui a été présenté hier en conseil des
ministres justement sur le
cyber-harcèlement les personnes
condamnées pour cyber-racellement pour
être bannis des réseaux sociaux pour six
mois voire un an en cas de récidive ça
c'est une bonne chose là aussi c'est une
vraie avancée oui pour assainir un petit
peu les usages sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est bien parce que le
cyber-harcèlement c'est un fléau un vrai
fléau qui ne touche pas que les
personnes qui ont une certaine notoriété
mais enfin ça touche aussi tout
n'importe quelle utilisateur et avec des
désastre des conséquences désastreuses
donc je pense que c'est une bonne chose
et en plus enfin si on
l'idée c'est qu'on ne puisse pas
cautionner que des personnes qui ont un
rayonnement donc des influenceurs qui
puissent eux faire de leur propre nem
and shame et venir donc cyber-harceler
d'autres personnes on sait que c'est ces
attitudes vont aussi ruisser les et
aller chez chaque utilisateur donc
effectivement interdire le
cyber-harcèlement des influenceurs
n'aura que des conséquences positives
pour après le tout à chacun utilisateur
des réseaux un mode conclusion mais le
caca est-ce que vous pensez que le texte
voté par les sénateurs peut marquer un
tournant dans le monde de l'influence et
dans la pratique des influenceurs alors
il marquera nécessairement un tournant
et d'ailleurs le caractère transpartisan
unanimement à partager partout ça et je
trouve un élément important à rappeler
ça montre bien aujourd'hui que nous
avons tous conscience de l'intérêt du
texte de l'intérêt aujourd'hui d'avoir
un cadre légal clair on le redit mais
qui existait mais aujourd'hui qui est
vraiment annoncé assumé donc oui pour ma
part et je l'espère ça marquera un
tournant et j'espère que la CMP qui
arrive en tout cas et je n'ai pas
beaucoup enfin je l'espère je vois là
au travers en tout cas des échanges dans
les deux assemblées parlementaires
j'estime que on pourra aller sur un
texte équilibré partagé par tous merci
il nous reste 10 secondes j'ai 10
secondes simplement on espère aussi que
les plateformes type annuaires de
annuaire d'influenceurs ne seront pas
demain continuer enfin qui ne seront pas
considérés comme agent influenceurs
aujourd'hui le texte le prévoit et c'est
un problème ce ne sont pas des agences
c'est des annuaires et des plateformes
de mise en relation donc on y sera
sensible aussi voilà c'est dit si vous
voulez bien rester avec nous on va
regarder ensemble ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et Audrey on parle rien du se
réalisation de la France à la une de la
presse régionale et d'après La Dépêche
du Midi ça pourrait être une manière
pour Emmanuel Macron de tourner la page
après la séquence des retraites le chef
de l'État lance à partir d'aujourd'hui
de nombreux chantiers industriels pour
montrer que la France va de l'avant
malgré la contestation toujours active
ça commence aujourd'hui par une réunion
à l'Élysée sur le thème comment
accélérer notre réindustrialisation et
demain le chef de l'État se déplace à
Dunkerque pour acter l'implantation
d'une énorme usine de batterie pour
véhicules électriques avant une série de
déplacements la semaine prochaine sur ce
même thème d'après les experts c'est une
manière pour Emmanuel Macron d'occuper
l'espace médiatique avec l'espoir
peut-être de relancer de lancer enfin
son second quinquennat un sujet que la
montagne place en manchette la
réindustrialisation enjeu de
souveraineté Macron lance cette semaine
une opération reconquête fin de citation
la montagne qui fait aussi c'est une sur
un sujet qui a retenu mon attention
Oriane la sobriété ça paye dans le
contexte de la hausse des prix les
énergies de nombreuses communes ont dû
faire en urgence des réductions de leur
compte de consommation de gaz et
d'électricité et finalement les
résultats sont plutôt satisfaisants
clairement fait en par exemple a décidé
d'éteindre l'éclairage public de minuit
à 6h du matin sur une partie de son parc
résultat moins 18% de consommation
d'énergie à celles sur du rôle la mairie
trop difficile à chauffer à déménager
dans la salle des associations moins 80%
de consommation alors ces actions prises
dans l'urgence pourraient finalement
être pérennisé Oriane et dans un
contexte économie des ressources
sud-ouest s'intéresse aux piscines
privées oui on apprend que la France est
championne d'Europe des bassins privés
deuxième marché mondial après les
États-Unis après l'interdiction de la
vente de piscine hors sol dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales dans un contexte de
sécheresse évidemment le quotidien se
demande s'il ne faut pas généraliser
cette interdiction et même l'étendre à
toutes les piscines privées et puis je
termine avec une question je sais pas si
vous avez une âme d'artiste autour de
cette table sachez que ce week-end plus
de 300 artistes alsaciens ouvrent les
portes de leurs ateliers au public c'est
ce que nous apprennent les dernières
[Musique]